економічно щур продуктове ембарго
чи схожа russian people can i
жив його головна повертання а статусу
засланні держави Михайловичу явного
соціологи стоїть жуйку там є путіна
варишся в цій проблемі зате на мою думку
вивіз нові сили завтра заходу лапід
ринку space 3
і сьогоднішній сьогоднішні коливани rate
іншого шляху накрали та я правда
загину спочатку астя кримська кампанія
до відриваючи даси
ну і астані slide пов'язаний сирію на
фокус-групах нам говорять що ми губочан
мати нашу you are my cool і наші ракети
отримав вапняних кораблів це
полетіли зміг ланцюга твій jute результати
нашого мера презентації вно wowp цього
не я не буду говорити ще знову пряму
асада червона проти тероризму
циклу чого думка-то ідея наших лідерів
ваш кілерів у всякому і Петра мого
дівочі вулиці з і ризику в серії
відбутися робота на благо в ім'я добра
що маячня біля води вас на калашному зв'язку
світ я до провалу зах марні rate in вели
до риф характерно реса авторитарних
режимі вдовицю дня вільно кулі точно як
караян титану закладення змії є
припущення що ми отримали у
пушкіні що ми у тримай музики з-під
варення про підсумки колими сьогодні
читаємо досвіду ваня у мене такий вираз
хто цінностей тихо мати до думки
скільки нас правді ароматика думка тіла
вежі та скільки на громадську думку
телевізора 15 патріотизму та на вигляд
націоналізму цін ця кава плюси для
путина процес кажуть захисниць повтори
сочі
тишків на імперській drennan відпочила у
намагалася а за бортом
дуже сильна ізоляція маленька група
ти хто критий що ставиться дата взагалі
за розвивається і в Росії, і сім'я Росії
про сонячну плиту ти повелася в
ізоляції і в Росії, і в ім'я Росії
зовнішньої політики он і душист народжують
ще речовини ціла їх у загален з прямо
це
не проводжай, а вже таке російсько поважає
ось така витрата на дугу російського
політолога дмитро орешкіна над Левином і в
сирі та конфлікт на донбасі у витрати у
для кремля лиж не значення його намагається
забути потім його на мага юті забуду там
ще хочеться / це виглядає не допомогли
а не виходьте попаримо вікон і маємо цьому
давайте ви до нас можете своєї свідомості
якін і був імідж цього не було соціологи
страждають що тільки затяжна економічно
щур може хвилини став не русский до
владою проте на їх не думає стрільця
падіння right now чаків один у роті у
руси політичний лідер часто зустрічаю
популярніші устілки після слова вид ходу